oui je me suis même fait peur un jour je
me suis assise sur le quai du métro sur
les fautes sur les chaises parce que
voilà enfin j'ai vraiment sauter très
très loin c'était alors juste avant
d'arriver sur TPMP et en fait c'est très
très chagrin d'amour c'était une une un
amour on va dire que ça voilà
mais vraiment c'est le seul point
positif c'est que j'avais perdu 17 kg
parce que je ne mange plus je les ai
repris malheureusement parce que je
préfère comme ça que que
c'est une vraie la dépression c'est une
véritable maladie donc c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt pas mal d'en parler je
trouve moi j'ai eu un père dépressif
pendant des années et je me suis dit
tiens il veut pas s'en sortir il a pas
la bonne molécule truc et puis je suis
tombé dans la dépression après les
enfants en fait il y a des Blues ah
ouais le passe-partum en fait mais qui a
duré
longtemps en fait alors pas pour les
trois mais j'en ai eu un ou je voilà et
j'ai compris qu'en fait vous avez trois
enfants oui vous savez pas que je
croyais que vous aviez un enfant moi
la différence entre les idées noires et
la dépression parce que des idées noires
je pense quand même c'est souvent
la dépression c'est quand même un
extrême genre on a tous des moments un
peu de bas et après la dépression c'est
Roro ou excusez vécu est-ce que vous
auriez pu légitimement avoir des idées
noires et vous dire ça mais ça c'est
terminé j'arrête tout j'ai rideau je
veux ça fait en fait ça fait partie du
processus d'acceptation en fait donc il
y a des moments effectivement il y a des
moments de dépression alors elles sont
plus ou moins longues c'est des périodes
ouais c'est des périodes plus ou moins
longues qui arrivent plus ou moins tôt
après l'accident mais ça fait partie du
processus d'acceptation on on passe tous
par là voilà moi j'ai eu de la chance
j'ai pas connu trop trop c'est ces
périodes là elles ont été elles ont été
assez courtes mais et oui effectivement
en fait c'est comme un deuil le handicap
on fait le deuil de ce qu'on était avant
donc en fait il y a des étapes la colère
la tristesse etc on dit que cinq phases
d'acceptation pour
est-ce que la notoriété vous avez péter
les plombs en même temps
ils sont toujours restés ils ont
toujours été là et ils m'ont mis une
petite branlée à un moment voulu en
disant ça fait quelques temps que c'est
pas toi et ils m'ont mis une petite roue
c'est ça ma recadré un petit peu parce
que j'étais parti un petit peu un petit
peu loin j'ai un petit un petit peu pris
le melon je pense bien sûr alors vous
n'en parle en même temps c'est pas si
vite quand même le dans les films il
faut un acteur où on travaille tout le
temps sans être forcément
ultra connu et être très bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous la racontiez vous étiez
insupportable personne et tout parce que
comme vous aviez fait la couverture je
me rappelle de Paris Match je sais plus
ce que c'était gala etc avec Flavie
Flament le titre c'était nous sommes la
dream team
moi sur le loft j'étais pas en reste
donc à Nono était pas mal enfermé que
vous aviez le melon et vous avez
pas le melon mais si on rentre en hélico
tous les soirs chez soi
[Applaudissements]
mais non je ne rentrerai pas tous les
soirs de Nico merci
c'est toi qui l'a dit je vais la
raconter 200 je
faisais l'émission Secret le loft le
Secret Story j'étais voilà en train de
me séparer de la dream team justement
comme j'avais mon fils avec moi pendant
les vacances de juillet que Secret Story
était pendant les mois de juillet retour
je faisais des allers-retours pour
pouvoir être avec lui un petit peu le
temps pour le coucher et le bisou du
coup du coucher et comme ma maison était
à 250 220 km de Paris pour être là avant
qu'il se couche fallait aller très vite
vous pouvez nous rappeler la facture de
tout ça alors attendez j'arrive donc
j'avais demandé à TF1 euh demander à TF1
j'ai dit que je veux bien faire
l'émission mais je voudrais arrêter je
peux finir et on a partagé 55 ans les
frais d'hélico voilà donc 50% à machin
50% à la chair de téléphone
pour TF1 pour vous
donc voilà et donc je partais après
l'émission de 18h et quelques et je
m'étais 40 minutes pour arriver chez moi
donc pour combien tout ça
mais comme ça a été balancé à la presse
à l'époque il y a pas des réseaux j'en
ai pris plein la gueule parce qu'on a
dit que j'avais le melon parce que
j'avais demandé un hélico etc c'est vrai
que globalement quand au monde à Nico
c'est qu'on a à peu près le boulot
maintenant
c'est tout
vous savez combien ça coûte un
transatlantique en jet privé
en jet privé en Falcon de 900 et on a
beaucoup de 300000 €. je vous conseille
de prendre la viande voilà
Benji que dans les PMU de France j'ai
beaucoup de notoriété française
comme j'ai commencé très jeune j'avais
20 ans quand j'ai commencé sur M6 c'est
hyper jeune vous imaginez à 20 ans donc
j'avais super bien ma vie moi je venais
je sais pas c'est bien visiblement
assez modeste et tout donc j'avais quand
même pas mal d'argent et j'en ai profité
et j'étais pas mal longue mais genre
vraiment je faisais pas la teuf comment
on fait à 20 ans quoi et c'était cool ah
oui je suis un peu je me sentais un peu
ouais invincible mais parce que c'est
chouette
voilà ça redescend hein
mais c'est normal ça dépend de combien
on tombe en fait c'est c'est toujours
une question à l'échelle voilà c'est bon
dire voilà alors c'est compliqué
généralement vous voyez c'est rebondit
pas tout de suite voilà
vous demander peut-être comment perdre
quelques kilos
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez vous voyez ça vous voyez
quand c'est George Clooney ou Brad Pitt
là
tout le monde trouve ça formidable hein
on fait pas de blague
qui font du Chanel comme ça
un produit populaire ça devient honteux
tu as raison vous savez quoi je vous
emmerde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]